[Music]
I'd like to welcome Cynthia to work to
our fireside chat today and to your MS
REI
English lecture coming up in the next
hour Cynthia is the Gordon McKay
professor at Harvard University the
Radcliffe Alumni professor at the
Radcliffe Institute for Advanced Study
and affiliated faculty at Harvard Law as
well as a distinguished scientist at
Microsoft Research welcome thank you
it's good to be here I wanted to start
off with thinking about your background
of the the breadth of topics you've
worked on in computer science I wanted
to ask you how you got into computer
science and then and then how you chose
the problems the breadth the problems
that you've worked on from from
cryptography to to privacy and now now
fairness so that's a broad question I
got into computer science initially on a
lark when I was applying to college my
mother said maybe you should consider
applying to the engineering school I was
applying to Princeton I said why not and
I checked the box and so I started in
computer science at that time it was
Electrical Engineering and computer
science and I pretty much liked my first
year I started the circuits course in my
second year and I didn't like it and I
switched out of the School of
Engineering and wouldn't come back until
they they waived the requirement for the
circuits course and then in a junior
year I I met formal languages and
automata theory and I just fell in love
when I was ready to graduate I decided I
wanted to continue my studies and I went
to Cornell and studied theory and my
first work was in distributed computing
and I did that for a number of years I
was heavily influenced by Nancy Lynch
who had come from MIT to give a talk
when I was a graduate student at Cornell
and I postdoc for her and I I at a
certain point we needed Lohmann so in
distributed computing you're often
talking about good guys computing in the
presence of some bad guys that are
to disrupt the computation and it's very
natural that you might use cryptography
to hide information from the bad guys
and what we discovered was that the
kinds of cryptography that existed the
cryptography that sort of captured
privacy from a passive eavesdropper when
messages are going back and forth is not
the same as what you needed when the the
adversary is playing the same game as
all of the good guys so we needed
basically a different kind of
cryptography and so I ended up studying
cryptography and I got into develop
something called non malleable
cryptography together with moneena or
and Danny to love and then I I loved
crypto and I did that for quite some
time and eventually sort of around the
year 2000 I was talking to the
philosopher Helena Simone who studies
philosophical issues that arise in the
context of new technologies and
Nissenbaum was studying what does
privacy mean in public and what does
privacy mean when we have video cameras
all over the place and I got very
intrigued and I looked for a piece of
the privacy puzzle that sort of
theoretical computer science and
cryptography might be able to say
something about and crypto had developed
a lot of language for talking about
partial information and that seemed like
a good beginning and that is how I got
into privacy and led to differential
privacy eventually that's fascinating
I'm so these these topics that you're
that you've been working on from in both
privacy and then now fairness these are
age-old problems right that philosophers
ethicists and you know the legal legal
scholars have have been thinking about
for for centuries and now you've brought
I think a very new perspective the
computer science a theoretical
perspective
I'm kind of curious you know since you
you've been doing that from how has that
perspective you think shaped or affected
the broader discussion about about
privacy and and now I guess how people
are thinking about fairness so I don't
think that what we've done in privacy
preserving data analysis really
addresses large questions about how
people feel about privacy it was a very
specific corner of the general privacy
puzzle we did look a bit to the legal
and the philosophical literature as to
help us try to articulate specific
privacy concerns
I mean legal scholars and philosophers
will try to find very precise language
to capture things that people feel and
why they feel the way they do so we got
help from them more than vice-versa
in the fairness domain I think that
[Music]
there's some chance that the data
analytic tools can help shine spotlight
on how people think and where there are
unfairness and biases that so we may get
some we may get some help on the bigger
questions from the from the technology
do you so I'll of that you mentioned the
interplay between computer science and
other disciplines and borrowing ideas
from them and now perhaps feeding back a
little as well and trying to figure out
the solutions to these challenges
together how do you go about engaging
with people outside of our home
discipline how do I go about it so I
guess research like any other kind of
research so
there's usually there's some sort of
starting point I'll be like in the
privacy domain i my interest was piqued
by innocent um in other areas in
fairness I could start immediately
looking for people who think about
questions of distributive justice who
think about gender bias and medicine who
think about racial bias and when you
have some successful conversations with
people they're sort of kind and refer
you to their friends so I've been
tremendously lucky and had the
opportunity to talk to a lot of people
this way so networking I guess yes and
reading a lot of reading do you think do
you think computer science as a whole is
does enough of this type of engagement
or just the right amount or I'm curious
so I think that I think that computer
scientists more than ever have to start
thinking about ethics and being educated
about ethics that computer science is
moving into a position of tremendous
power and with that comes ethical
responsibilities at the same time
everybody has his or her own strengths
and interests and for the people who
only want to study one kind of thing
deeply I certainly wouldn't want to
derail them so I think naturally we're
going to have a big mix but I do feel
that that students should be educated
about ethics and Harvard is moving in
that direction in computer science as
well so I had an ethicist come and speak
and work with the class in the class
that I taught most recently and several
other people are doing this when we were
talking earlier
this morning you mentioned that you
thought that the work you're doing now
in in bias is a lot more challenging in
some ways than your earlier work on
differential privacy I'm kind of curious
if you could say a little bit more about
that sure so I think that defining bias
is much much tougher so the first thing
that you want to do if you want to have
a technical solution that helps with at
least some aspect of a bias problem is
to define what biases or to define what
is the unfairness that you're trying to
combat in your particular corner of the
technological universe so when we were
talking about privacy and we kind of had
narrowed it down to privacy preserving
data analysis which was a much smaller
scope than privacy in general we could
think about different definitions of
privacy and we came up with one which is
a rather robust and it captures many
intuitions about what constitutes
privacy in data analysis and so you know
you come up with it you develop methods
that insure it and there's not
controversy about what you're doing it
may or may not do everything but it does
what it says it does and people don't
argue that what it says it's doing is a
bad thing it's only a good thing now
when it comes to fairness things go all
over the place so for example you could
say well I want to have a classifier and
I want it to be I want I want to ensure
what we call demographic parity that is
the number the fraction of people in a
given demographic group that are let's
say receiving a positive classification
should be the same as this fraction of
this demographic group in the population
as a whole is that fair or isn't it is
affirmative-action fair or isn't it if
you if
you are looking at cases where you're
trying to make predictions and you're
going to have some error because you
know the future is not knowable do you
require equal false positive rates and
false negative rates across groups or
not and what are the consequences of
these things so it's a lot of natural
definitions natural desiderata are
mutually exclusive what do you do about
that
what can you ask your system to do when
these various things that you want are
mutually exclusive you have to come to
some kind of a social agreement as to
what you mean by fair and what's
appropriate for your setting and I'm
starting to understand that this is a
fundamentally political process and my
politics education is just beginning so
do you think the role of the language
and framework the theory behind fairness
is about showing the options to
policymakers and legal folks or what
rolled youth do you see okay so first of
all I should mention there is a
definition that I like although it too
has all sorts of problems and the
definition that I like is what we're
calling individual fairness which says
intuitively that given a particular
classification task individuals who are
similar with respect to that
classification task should be classified
similarly should have similar
probabilities of positive classification
for example and of course a problem with
that is well how do we determine who is
similar to whom for this task what is
the metric what is the measure of
distance of similarity or dissimilarity
between two people and even if you had
your hands on the metric how do you know
that it's the right one so an example
that I like to think about is let's say
that that we have a very nice news
organization and we're looking to
you hire people to our news organization
and so we want to predict who is likely
to succeed at the news organization and
we have a very crisp definition of
success you stay three years with the
company at least and you have at least
one promotion in those three years so
success is well defined so then you want
to say somehow that if you have two
people who are similarly likely to
succeed then they should have the same
probabilities of getting a job offer or
similar probabilities of getting the job
offer now
so now let's change the problem and we
say well we needs not such a nice news
organization maybe it's a news
organization that has historically been
hostile to women so now for two equally
talented individuals one male and one
female it may be that the man is more
likely to succeed than the woman because
the atmosphere is hostile so wait should
the metric be capturing likelihood of
success or should the metric in fact be
Talent in the nice news organization
talent predicts your success in the
nasty news organization talent is
insufficient to predict success so you
need to exercise like thought and
judgment about what should the
classifiers be doing and how do you use
them on the other hand when you actually
formalize the problem it becomes
abundantly clear that the issue is
hostility in the work environment so
there's something that's gained
immediately from the formalization of
the problem so you brought up the issue
of these algorithms accidentally
learning from society's biases and and
amplifying them potentially in the
decisions that they make and the that's
one source of bias that I hear people
talking about my also hear people
talking about about data biases where
the data that's used to train an
algorithm is perhaps an insufficient
representation of what goes on though in
the world maybe it's biased through some
selection mechanism or collection
mechanism
do you see these two types of biases as
two sides of the same coin or do you
think that they're they're different and
require different approaches to address
so I'm not actually clear what you mean
in your first example in fact when you
were saying your first example I thought
that you meant the second that is that
the the biases are imbibed in the
Mother's Milk of the training data so
then what's learned it's not an accident
that it's learned it wasn't the
intention of the algorithm designer to
teach the algorithm to be biased but the
biases are just brought in there from
the historical training data let's see
the so I was thinking about the two
kinds of biases I was thinking about was
one where there's an existing bias in us
in an organization like that versus
another one where the organization is
not biased but perhaps the the data that
you collected about employee success was
selected in such a way to not be
representative of the of that
organization so clearly a biased
organization is giving rise to what I
would call biased historical data and so
probably if I'm interpreting your
question correctly the answer is yes
these are two sides of the same coin all
right yeah I guess in one case you have
opportunities to go and collect more
data and the other one you can't so this
is another you're alluding to something
else which is just lack of
representation and lack of
representation presents its own problems
and historically has presented bad
problems and one can collect more data
and one can also sort of be smarter
about exploration exploitation
trade-offs and so there's starting to be
a nice literature on this sort of thing
in in the you know fair algorithms world
but I think also that if I'm not
mistaken economists were also aware of
this so you have two populations a
minority population and a majority
population you know the majority very
well what kinds of incentives can you
offer a bank for giving loans to the
minority population so that that
population becomes better known so these
questions are not entirely new these
questions of lack of representation are
not entirely new and I think we should
be thinking a lot in terms of what sorts
of things can we do to encourage the the
increasing of the datasets and balancing
out so that we get much more informed
views and how do we bring in experts on
different populations and include them
in the discussion of what constitutes
fair and what are the right criteria to
be to be using for the different groups
I think that I know that there's some
interest in having say classifiers that
suppress the information of the
demographic group and my guess is that
or not my guess we know specifically
that there are situations in which doing
this leads to reduced utility that
having context allows you to to make
better judgments where do you see think
the future lies in in fairness do you
see that do you think that will make a
significant headway in the next few
years from either practical or
theoretical point of view or do you
think that it'll that it's a long ways
off yet given the politics and the
social aspects of challenge of the
problem
I think real progress on the
mathematical side will will will be
relatively rapid that I'm seeing just in
the last couple of years a real
gathering of strength and and a plethora
of new ideas and variations on the
definitions that try to bridge the
individual versus the group in in very
exciting ways there's also there are
also some extremely intriguing
approaches coming up in the deep
learning community so so I think that
this is this is going really well
I don't believe there will be a an
alternative to having discussions that
bring in politics and ethics and
[Music]
economics and so on and I think that the
charges to these communities are going
to go up and you're gonna say you know
we need help with this that and the
other thing so I think things will make
progress but I don't I don't see yet our
way to finding a single crisp definition
of what fair is that will really capture
what we want all the time from an an
algorithm a fair algorithm and that will
behave very well under what we call
composition we haven't spent any time
talking about these very important
questions of if you have a system that
has a bunch of pieces each of which is
fair what happens you know what can you
say about fairness of your system in
toto altogether and in other scenarios
in in cryptography and in differential
privacy people know how to talk about
composition these and ensure nice
composition properties but in the
fairness domain things are much more too
cult and we get initial results are very
negative and we have to work hard to
ensure fairness together so that's great
to hear I think we're out of time and
your talk is gonna be coming up soon
thank you very much Cynthia for coming
it's been a pleasure talking with you
the pleasure has been mine thank you so
much